today on the matt wall show an msnbc
host claims that most american school
kids are being taught that slavery is
okay
that's what she thinks is happening in
school school rooms today
this is the kind of hallucinatory world
that the critical race theory proponents
live in
so we'll talk about that also five
headlines including a new report about
the rash of suicide attempts by
adolescent girls
during lockdown and we have video of a
female student
coming out as a guy to her classmates
which is as disturbing as you might
expect plus a lobster diver claims he
was swallowed by a whale
it's an important story we have to talk
about that in our daily cancellation
we'll talk about the npr
article blasting tom hanks for making
too many movies about white people doing
good things that's very problematic
as we'll see all of that and much more
today on the matt wall show
[Music]
now a new sponsor on the show carnivore
trading you know if you want to get
into the market into trading it's really
important to seek advice from people
who are who know what they're talking
about there's a lot of bad advice out
there how do you get good advice good
guidance
well the thing is wall street has been
lying for years saying seven percent
is a good return on our stocks it's not
and also that trading is so complex you
need a financial advisor
you don't real people are making 30 50
even 100 a year on their money trading
stocks even when the uh when the market
is tough
carnivore trading is an anonymous team
of elite wall street strategists
that's where you're getting your
guidance there are legends among wall
street heavy hitters and now they've
gone a bit rogue
they're allowing everyday folks like us
to see and mirror their explosive trades
sounds too good to be true true
carnivore will let you see the trades
they're making right now for free
um you know i'm no expert myself so this
is something that i need i think you do
probably too
go to get ourtrades.com and use promo
code walsh to get two weeks free and if
you join carnivore guarantees you'll get
five times your subscription fee or
double your money back
uh go to get our trades dot com promo
code walsh get our trade dot com promo
code walsh
c website for guaranteed terms and
conditions past performance not a
guarantee
of future earnings you know the odd
thing about the defenders of critical
race theory is that they don't often
defend it
maybe you've noticed that it's a common
tactic of the left
generally rather than outright defend
whatever idea they put forth or whatever
dogma they indoctrinate our children
into
they instead accuse its critics of being
you know brainless bigots who don't
understand it
the tactic almost always is to make the
idea more obscure
more vague the more the more obscure and
vague the idea the more insulated from
criticism it is
if you object to it then they simply
scoff and inform you that this is a
topic for academics and scholars and
educated people and you're simply too
uneducated to engage in the discussion
this is why while crt proponents accuse
its
opponents of being unable to define crt
they themselves are
unwilling or unable to define it a very
similar tactic has been used with antifa
you've noticed
we we've been told that those who
criticize those who criticize antifa
simply don't understand what antifa is
or what it stands for
and yet those who offer this
rationalization are always very
reluctant
to paint any kind of definite picture
themselves
it's appropriate that brandy zedrazney
nbc news senior reporter that is
propagandist
compared the two things in an effort to
defend both she wrote on twitter
a couple days ago quote critical race
theory is the new antifa
and it's just so frustrating to see this
boogeyman political tactic work over and
over again
antifa and crt are boogie men does that
mean they don't exist
no they do exist we're told but they
just they're not what we think they are
okay so then what are they
well we wouldn't understand for another
example of this strategy crt guru ibram
x kendi was
interviewed by slate a few days ago and
the very first question posed to him
i mean it was an interview about
critical race theory first question
very simple what actually is critical
race theory
he's the expert on the subject allegedly
he says the critics don't understand it
can't define it
now it's his chance to offer the real
definition
sounds good this is what he said this
was his answer
critical race theory emerged among
lawyers and legal scholars who
recognized
that despite being in this post-civil
rights america racial inequality or
rather sorry racial inequity and
disparity
still existed and persisted for them and
for critical race theorists
the aim was to examine those structures
those laws those policies
so that we can uncover the structures of
racism and obviously critical race
theory
has extended out to other disciplines
personally i think the republicans
specifically chose to attack critical
race theory because they felt that they
could define it more easily than other
terms
since they couldn't come out and say oh
those people who are challenging
systemic racism are a problem
they couldn't say those anti-racists are
a problem so they're defining critical
race theory at the same time that
they're attacking it
and critical race theories theorists are
like that's not how we define it
uh okay ibram then how do you define it
because that wasn't a definition that
was a bunch of words
but it wasn't a definition see this
should be your first clue that something
is wrong
when the people advancing an idea don't
want to explain it to you
or they insist that they can't explain
it because you wouldn't understand it if
they did
that's a common strategy not only among
leftists but also among cult leaders
scientologists are also very reluctant
to tell you what scientology actually
is and what does that tell you
in this case they don't want to explain
it straightforwardly because
in truth critical race theory is simply
the idea
that everything in america is racist and
all white people are racist
and all minorities are victims and
vengeance must be enacted
on the racist white people in order to
settle the score
that's what it is i mean we can dance
around and use lots of bigger words if
we want
but but i think when it comes down to it
that's the most accurate distillation
of critical race theory four basic
points america is racist
two white people are racist three
minorities are victims four vengeance
right crt culsa cultists will object to
that definition
i'm sure but even when they object
you'll notice
that they won't disagree with any of
those four points
they'll only say that i'm simplifying
which i am because unlike them i
actually want people to understand what
i'm saying
for all the reasons so far outlined when
trying to um
understand what critical race there is
in practice it's better to look at
examples of it i mean what does it do to
a person's mind
what sort of things does a person come
to believe
once they've sacrificed their brain to
this cult
well for a case study and people who've
given up their brains there's probably
no better place to look
than to joy read on msnbc providing some
very
illuminating insight into the world view
of a crt religionist
joy recently tweeted the following she
said quote
open question to those who are afraid of
critical race theory which isn't being
taught in k-12 schools
it's of course offered in law schools
but you clearly are conflating it with
the 1619 project
what do you want taught about u.s
slavery and racism
nothing or what currently
listen to this most k-12 students
already learn a kind of confederate race
theory
whereby the daughters of the confederacy
long ago imposed a version of history
wherein slavery was not so bad and had
nothing to do with the civil war and
lynchings and violence never happened
is this about continuing to teach
confederate race theory
and continuing to omit things like the
founding the founders owning slaves
or the facts about the mass
extermination of the indigenous
are you insisting that those things
continue to be omitted
if so why or is it about adding more
empty praise to the teaching of history
and completing the sanitization of
history
that already is the case if so why how
does that make children smarter
and don't you think kids will eventually
find out the facts anyway would love a
response
well okay i'll give you a response um
before we get to get the response though
uh
as requested uh i will give that but we
should note that
she's far from alone in this point of
view another quick example robert reich
former secretary of labor current
berkeley professor
so you kind of know what you're going to
get from him made a slightly more toned
down
version of joy reid's argument in a
recent video let's watch that
the so-called party of free speech is
now going after academic freedom a host
of republican-controlled states have
passed or
are gearing up to pass bills that ban
teaching
the role race has played in the history
of american politics
policy and law conservatives lobbed the
term critical race theory against the
nation's tragic racial history they
don't want students to know
calling it indoctrination or
brainwashing well as an educator i can
tell you that the real
indoctrination in brainwashing is in
leaving out this history and only
teaching children the myths
that we've always been a perfect country
always lived up to our ideals and
there's no need to reckon
with our past that's dangerous unless
our children know
all of our history including the
anguished role racism
has played in shaping this country they
can't possibly understand why we are
where we are today
and what we can and must do to better
live up to our ideals
the stories we tell about ourselves
matter and it's about time we started
telling
the truth well first of all
none of this has anything to do with
free speech
public school teachers don't have free
speech rights to teach kids whatever
they want
so this whole this this what the left is
doing here by painting this as a free
speech issue is absurd
now leftists right now are pretending to
think otherwise pretending to think that
you know this is a this is free speech
and public school teachers have free
speech rights and they should be able to
teach whatever they want
and they're taking that approach now
because it suits them but let's see how
they react if an eighth grade social
studies teacher
begins class by informing her students
that jesus christ is their lord and
savior
that's a religious conviction that they
will say in that case has no place in
the classroom
and in that case that teacher should be
fired should maybe go to jail there
should be lawsuits
crt is also a religious conviction it's
a cult belief
that has no place in the classroom i
mean the very idea that state
governments
can't pass laws to determine what will
be taught in government schools
is is just asinine but asinine doesn't
even begin to describe the rest of what
we heard from both robert reich and joy
reid
in what school in what universe
are kids not already being taught about
racism
where is that happening or not happening
what school is giving kids a mythical
version of american history
where racism doesn't exist at all and
never existed
and played no factor
to the contrary one of the only facts
that most americans seem to know about
american history
is that there was racism and there was
slavery and both of those things are bad
every american knows that every american
has been taught that in school
that's been the case for a very long
time but reid goes even further
she claims that most american school
children are being taught that slavery
isn't so bad
she she wants to know if uh if crt
critics
think that kids should continue to be
taught that
the answer is no they shouldn't continue
to be taught that slavery isn't bad
just as they shouldn't continue to be
taught that cannibalism is an acceptable
dietary practice
and just as you know cows should not
continue flying over the moon
i think they should stay down here on
earth frankly
see nothing can continue to happen if it
isn't already happening
anywhere at all period
there are no slavery apologetics
or slavery justifications being offered
in any school or
any classroom anywhere in america
at all and i'll even go on a limb and
say
there are zero exceptions to that
because usually you know with
it's hard to make any blankets like you
can always find an anomalous case
somewhere of someone doing something
crazy
but but in this case you know what i'm
gonna say you won't even find one
example
anywhere of anything like what joey reid
describes
indeed once again one of the only facts
about america that
every u.s citizen knows is that slavery
happened
and it was very bad you can walk up to
any person on the street
and they can tell you that
in fact i i again i'll go further and
say walk up to any person on the street
and just ask them tell me a fact about
american history
the majority of them that's one of the
first things they're going to tell you
they can also probably tell you that we
landed on the moon at some point
and there was a guy named george
washington who may or may not have been
around
when the moon landing happened those are
all the facts that most americans know
about their country
slavery is definitely among the facts
crt cultists think that school kids
aren't being told enough about america's
racist past
meanwhile in reality that's about the
only thing that school kids are reliably
told about their country's history at
least it's one of the only things they
retain
because it's emphasized so much
and that's exactly how we ended up in a
country where something like critical
race theory
is so prominent and powerful that's the
great irony here
that some people i think have missed
critical race theory is
disproven by its own existence if we
lived in the kind of country that joy
reid described where millions of
american school kids
are being indoctrinated to believe that
slavery is good
or not so bad critical race theory
could have never come into existence and
certainly wouldn't have the prominence
it does today
no crt exists because kids are being
indoctrinated
into the opposite extreme that's the
reality of the world we currently live
in
but crt as we've seen has no interest
in dealing with reality now let's get to
our five headlines
now a word from our sponsor with
probably my favorite name
moiq and one of my favorite products too
because it's all about food it's all
about meat
i would i would never describe myself as
a foodie
because that's cringey and lame but i do
enjoy
good food and that's why i love moink
moink delivers grass-fed and
grass-finished beef and lamb pastured
pork and chicken and wild-caught alaskan
salmon directly to your door
helping family farms become financially
independent outside of big agriculture
their animals are raised outdoors their
fish swim wild in the ocean and oink
meat is free of antibiotics hormones
sugar
all the other junk you find a
pre-packaged food you don't have to
worry about that with monk
sign up at mointbox.com walsh to get a
year of bacon for free who else do you
need to know get a year of free bacon
um also you should know moic was founded
by an eighth generation farmer who was
featured on shark tank
host kevin o'leary said it's the best
bacon he's ever tasted and it is so join
the monk movement today
go to moicbox.com walsh right now and
lists
and listeners to this show get free
bacon for a year
cannot emphasize that enough that's one
year of the best bacon you'll ever taste
but for a limited time
spelled m o i n k box dot com slash
walsh that's moicbox.com
walsh well uh the good news
anyway at least is that uh we have only
a three day week or at least
i have a three day week because i'm
going on vacation
uh leaving on uh on thursday you
probably still have to work the whole
week so
i can't do anything for you and the
other part of the good news again this
is only for me
is that um because we're going on
vacation and it's gonna be a lake
vacation
that gives me an excuse to go to bass
pro shops today
which um which i'm very excited about
people accuse me all the time of not
smiling i think that's it's
a slight i think that's a i think that's
fake news because i do smile at least
once or twice a week
but if you really want to see me smile
then you got to see me in a bass pro
shops that
that's like a kid in a candy shop and
the thing is um
you know i was explaining this plan to
my wife i said well
we're going on vacation i got to go buy
some more fishing tackle and stuff
and she said um well don't you have
enough
tackle enough lures and what i try to
explain to her is that
no that that doesn't that's not a thing
that doesn't exist that doesn't compute
you can't have enough what do you mean
enough that doesn't enough
fishing tackles not that's not a thing
it's like saying and she's also told me
this
that uh well you have enough ammo you
don't need to buy into more ammo
no there's no enough that's not a thing
you can't have enough
there are certain things in life you
can't have enough of fishing tackle ammo
those are two other things i'm sure
there are a few others
all right um let's start
with this from the new york post
back into something very serious and
depressing um
but also not at all unexpected
says from the new york post says suicide
attempts by adolescent girls
surged during the kova 19 pandemic
worsening as the second wave wore on
according to a new study
the number of emergency room visits for
suspected suicide attempts
for those 12-17 began to rise in may
2020 especially among girls
according to a study by the cdc the mean
number of weekly
such visits by girls during a month-long
period in the summer of 2020
was 26 percent higher than during the
same period in 2019
26 percent higher by the winter of 2021
the number of er visits for suspected
suicide attempts was 50 percent higher
than 2019
among the among boys the number of
visits rose by three
3.7 percent uh so
that that is that's an interesting
disparity um
the study theorized young people were at
higher risk because they might have been
hit hard by cover 19 safety measures
such as physical distancing and may have
felt increased anxiety about
family health and economic concerns
the cdc said quote the findings from
this study suggested
more severe distress among young females
than has been identified in previous
reports during the pandemic
reinforcing the need for increased
attention to and prevention for
this population um females are more
likely to report self-harm or suicide
attempts than males which may account
for the increased er visits by girls
also i you know if we're going to
speculate about about the
the disparity uh girls and women
are also more are more real are more
relational
you know and and um i think need that
interpersonal connection i mean boys do
also
but um girls are even
tend even more in that direction so i
could see how they'd be even more
affected by
by the isolation though again it affects
everybody
and especially kids now this is
horrible and infuriating
and it's made even more infuriating by
anyone who acts surprised by it
because this was entirely foreseeable
the people who are behind these quote
unquote safety measures like the cdc for
example
they can't act surprised this this you
100
you knew this was going to happen
knew it like looking into a crystal ball
you knew it with that clarity
we all did
if you have any understanding of human
beings
and how humans operate especially kids
you can't rip their entire lives away
from them and isolate them
isolation has an effect on people a
devastating effect and if you have kids
that are already struggling
emotionally um and then you isolate them
on top of all of the the the fear and
anxiety
that you're heaping on top of it telling
them you have to
wear a mask every time you leave the
house that's how afraid you should be
and it can't be emphasized enough we did
all of this
in spite of the fact that um there was
never any serious risk to kids
that's the one thing i i can never get
over
it's like blinding rage when i think
about it
we can't even claim although the the
people who push these policies will
claim
you cannot credibly claim that we did it
for them
this was something that was done to kids
knowing ahead of time the effect it
would have on them
again you can't claim you didn't know
because there were those of us saying
all along you cannot do this to kids
you're going to destroy them
you're going to have you're going to
have suicide epidemics you have kids in
emergency rooms
that is going to happen we said that
so knowing what would happen
we did this anyway because we were
scared for our own safety
and by we i mean the general universal
we i don't include myself
hopefully not you um
maybe i shouldn't be saying we at all
they you know i put it that way they
they did this knewing what knowing
knowing the effect i would have on kids
it's completely backwards
is i mean is anyone does anybody want to
step up to the plate
let me ask you does anyone want to step
up to the plate anyone in the vay
category
anyone who supported these policies you
want to step up to the plate and tell me
that this cost is worth it you want to
tell me that
look at the uh well we'll just take one
data point one statistical factor 26
percent rise
in suicide attempts among adolescent
girls
and we're only we're only we're zoning
in on one group here adolescent girls
what was it 12 to
17 26
rise in suicide attempts
is that is that worth it was it worth
the trade-off
whatever safety we allegedly
gained over the last year was it worth a
26
rise in suicide attempts among kids
because i got to tell you i can't think
of anything that would be worth it
that would be worth that cost i can't
think of any public policy
that could be put in place in any
situation
that would be worth the cost of a
massive rise in suicide attempts among
children
like i would rather have anything but
that
and if you tell me that well if we
didn't have all these policies it means
that maybe more people would have died
of covet don't think that's
dem that's i don't think that's true at
all
because kids were not it were not a high
risk factor to spread or
or contracted but even sake of argument
for the sake of argument let's say that
that's true
these measures that led to a 26 rise in
suicide attempts among among young girls
let's just say that uh yeah it did that
but it also prevented some people
from dying coveted who otherwise would
have
um i gotta tell you i i i would take the
coveted deaths
over thousands
of more kids trying to kill themselves
so i don't think the trade is worth it
at all
but if anyone wants to step up and say
that they think it is
say yeah you know that's kind of rough
but uh it was worth it
maybe fouchy i want voucher to get on tv
and say it was
yeah 26 rise in suicide attempts among
kids
it was worth it because if you're
defending the lockdowns even now then
that's what you think
and i want you to say it
here's someone who thinks it was
definitely worth it andy slavitt
um biden's kovitzar which i don't know
what he has to do
now i don't know i don't know what his
job i don't know what his job ever was
i'm certainly not sure what it is now
he says that uh the lesson that he takes
over from the past year is uh that
americans didn't sacrifice
enough let's watch how much
of this pandemic was preventable and how
well of course we would have had a uh
pandemic here in the u.s no matter what
um but but and look we can count the
the mistakes and i think it's important
that we do if for nothing else so we
don't repeat them
we obviously had a set of technical
mistakes with the testing and and the
the ppe that we know about
but if we're honest we also had two
other two other types of mistakes that
caused a lot of loss of life one were
just plainly political leadership
mistakes
um there was a lot we denied the virus
for too long out of the trump white
house
we there was too much squashing of
dissent and playing on divisions
but i'd also think we all need to look
at one another and ask ourselves
what do we need to do better next time
and in many respects
being able to sacrifice a little bit for
one another um to get through this and
to save more lives is going to be
it's going to be essential and that's
something that i think we could all have
done a little bit better on
oh yeah we didn't sacrifice enough not
not enough sacrifice
millions people lost their job
kids lost a year of education
uh which it shouldn't have gone that way
even if you shut down the schools for a
year there's no reason why kids should
lose education
because you could teach them at home but
the reality is that a lot
many kids just didn't really didn't get
an education of any kind for a year or
more
more than a year so sacrifice that year
of education
millions of jobs lives
of people committing suicide
including kids not enough that's the
lesson he takes
this tyrannical sociopathic scumbag
the lesson he takes is that next time he
wants more of that
more jobs gone more kids killing
themselves
that's what he wants
these people are pure evil you realize
that pure evil we're being we are being
led by
by people who are absolute pure evil to
their bones
speaking of which um mayor lori
lightfoot on cnn
was on cnn a couple days ago and she was
uh
trying to just she was discussing and
and attempting to justify the racist
policy that she had in place about
interviews you remember we talked about
this on the show a couple of times
she put a policy in place for a period
of time
where um she would only accept
interviews from journalists
who were who were non-white although she
didn't say that she didn't she didn't
come out and say i don't want to talk to
any of you
white devils what she said was she wants
to prioritize interviews from
journalists of color
and clearly racist illegal you can't do
that as a public official you can't say
i'm only going to talk to journalists of
a certain race
um so she's being sued for that
rightfully so she was on cnn
uh but she's not backing down or
apologizing in fact you know what
the people who are criticizing her they
are her oh her apology she's the victim
here of course
let's listen to her defense i want to
ask you about a lawsuit that you're the
target of and acknowledge that you are
talking to me this morning
and i by all accounts i'm a white guy uh
and we're doing this interview together
on one day on the anniversary of your
inauguration
you uh gave interviews to only reporters
of color
and you're being now sued for that on
the basis of discrimination your
reaction
well the lawsuit is completely frivolous
i'd use a more colorful term if we
weren't on tv
but here's the thing i'm the mayor of
the third largest city
in the country i'm an african-american
uh woman to state the obvious
every day when i look out across my
podium i don't see people who
look like me but more to the point i
don't see people who reflect
the richness and diversity of the city
so yes
i started a long overdue conversation
about diversity in newsrooms and
coverage
you all are the mirrors on society you
reflect
with a critical and important lens the
news of the day
you hold the public officials like me
accountable
you must be diverse it can't be that in
a city like chicago with all the talent
that we have
that we can't find diverse journalists
of color
of course we can what they need is
opportunity
and i hope my conversation has pricked
the consciousness
of the people who do the hiring
decisions in media rooms all
across the city and hopefully across the
country we've got to do better
oh she was just starting a conversation
what i love about that is
first of all justifying outright
bigotry as i'm just trying to start a
conversation
that's all uh but also
the insinuation that we that we're not
already having this conversation
you know what i was looking to do i was
looking to start a conversation about
race
you know i i figured we're not having
enough of those conversations
hey look i i did this and now everyone's
talking about race
coincidence i think not
yeah that's you know because that's
that's a conversation we really need to
get started
can we you know what can we finally talk
about race in this country
i've had enough of the silence
um but she uh i i'm glad that she went
on
cnn to give that interview while the
lawsuit is still
making its way through the process the
lawsuit is still active and she won it
because she disincriminated herself
what's the first thing she said you
could tell that she kind of noticed what
she said and
she she pivoted with the the more to the
point
pivot but she started by saying her
first point of justification was
i look from the podium and i don't see
people who look like me
so so what
what you're saying that you're only
going to talk to people who look like
you
yeah we know that and that see that's
that's racism that's excluding people
you're a public official
being racist excluding people who don't
look like you
and that's illegal you can't do that
i'm sure the um you know the lawyers
that are
in charge of this lawsuit i'm sure they
noticed that interview there because
that that to me is
that's like a that's a confession of
guilt
i don't see people who look like me me
so what get over yourself
who cares if they don't look like you
that's not their job and what do you
what is this we stuff
oh we we can find reporters of color and
diverse
what do you mean we who is the i don't
know what the
who the we is here you're in the
government it's not your job to find
reporters
i i can understand how you'd have this
confusion
right you think that they literally work
for you and i mean they basically do but
they don't literally work for you
all intents and purposes they do
but in reality legally it's not your job
or your place or your authority
to find reporters who you dane worthy of
talking to you
so just some outright bigotry there
always fun
now we have a another fun video this
went viral from uh my favorite site
tiktok
and this is a a coming out
sort of event to a group at a school i
think a college but uh i'm not sure
could be a high school i don't know how
you tell the difference these days
but um anyway let's watch
the uh this is a female coming out and
announcing
that in fact she's she's male um
this is kind of scary because i only
realized this a couple of days ago and
i've only come out to a few people
i'm a guy
[Applause]
and i'm going to go by theo
[Applause]
i told my mom today and i have to go
home
every day and be called my dead name
and have she her pronouns used every
time i go home
and no one realizes how hurtful it is
it's like a slap in the face
and i dyed my hair last night so i could
feel more masculine
and i was afraid i was gonna get thrown
out of the house we love you theo
okay she realized
talk about a cult right
she realized a a couple of days ago that
she's a guy
and already so i'm just going based on
what she said there but
so she's been a girl um
her whole life to this point and then a
couple days ago she realized
you know what i'm a guy and already it's
hurtful if
her parents continue to see her as the
girl
that that they they birthed and have
raised
like she thinks she could go home and
say hey by the way everything you've
ever known about me is completely wrong
um and you must immediately adapt to
what i am saying
right now and if you don't it is
devastatingly hurtful
it wasn't yesterday but it is today
of course knowing with these kinds of
statements no one can ever ask
really obvious questions that aren't
gotcha questions
they're not attacks and they're the kind
of questions you would ask if you really
wanted to understand what someone is
saying
and as i've said all along this stuff
that we're hearing about gender
when people come out as oh i'm a girl
i'm a guy
i'm non-binary i'm whatever i
i can only speak for myself i actually
want to understand
what you're trying to say i really do
and so when someone is a girl
and they wake up one morning and they
they realize that they're a guy
how like describe the process of
realizing this
what do you mean exactly
and follow-up question whatever feelings
you were experiencing
that you have decided our evidence that
you're actually a guy
how do you know that those are guy
feelings given that you
haven't been one these these are
basically are these basic questions
really fair questions nobody asks them
i mean i do but nobody else seems to and
so they don't get answered
um but this is a as i this is an
another cult it's all part of the you
know leftism itself is one big cult and
there are kind of offshoots
from it that diverge slightly in in
their emphasis
but uh this is another version of it
this is someone who's been
indoctrinated into it brainwashed into
it
a young young girl and how old she is
not very old
and and i feel bad for them you know the
blame that i put for all this
the gender madness i put it on the
adults who are pushing this stuff
i don't put it on the kids
you know because they've they there are
really normal sorts of emotions that you
experience as a kid
and as a person in general but speaking
about kids
they're very normal emotions there
there's there's
confusion which is really normal you
know
there's anxiety where
this kind of unsure you're not you're
unsure of yourself you're unsure of the
world you're unsure of your place in the
world
discomfort with your body all of that
is super normal especially for kids and
especially once
they have teenage years and they're
going through puberty and beyond that
and the hormones are raging and
everything else
all of that is really normal
but kids now have been given a framework
for understanding these normal feelings
and it's a tempting framework especially
for girls
which is why this this stuff is much
more common among adolescent girls and
physical
among adolescent boys but they've been
given a framework
and it's it's it seems very clarifying
in the moment
where they're told oh yeah you're
feeling all that way uh because you
actually you're a guy
don't worry about what that means
exactly or how that could possibly be
the case
uh anyone who who questions it is just a
bigot don't worry about them
but it means you're a guy and you could
start a whole new life and have a whole
new identity
you don't like your current identity you
feel a little uncomfortable with you're
feeling anxiety you're not you're not
liking
what's happening in school your peer
group you're not feeling accepted
well you can have a whole new identity
for yourself in a moment all you have to
do is just announce it just like that
it's very tempting for confused kids
and i put it on the adults it's all
their fault all right
we're gonna try to lighten things up a
little bit here um
because i i have to admit this story
i've seen it floating around
no pun intended for for a few days and
uh
as soon as i saw the headline first
thing i thought was
that's obviously false that's obviously
bs but
everyone else seems to to be accepting
it it's being reported as
fact it doesn't seem to be a lot of
criticism of it
no one's really asking speaking i'm not
asking questions no one seems to be
asking any questions about this is a
story about a lobster diver
who says he was swallowed by a whale and
then spit back out
and this is not something that he's no
this is like this happened supposedly a
week ago or something
so here's cape cod times with the
original report
it says that a little before 8 am friday
veteran lobster diver
michael packard entered the water for a
second dive of the day
his vessel the john jay
was off herring cove beach and
surrounded by a fleet of boats
catching striped bass the water
temperature was a balmy 60 degrees
and so on and so forth um licensed
commercial lobster divers literally
plucked lobsters off the sandy bottom so
he was diving down
and then in something truly biblical
packard was swallowed whole
by a humpback whale no he wasn't
uh that didn't happen he wasn't that
really didn't happen
uh he he was interviewed he said all of
a sudden i felt this huge shove the next
thing i knew it was completely black
he says he thought at first he was
swallowed by a great white
and then he realized it was a whale i
you know a great white's not
you'll know if you're in the jaws of a
great white i don't think there's going
to be any confusion
right i've never been eaten by a shark
but i don't think there's gonna be any
moment where you're like what's
happening right now i don't understand
oh i'm being gnawed to death no i think
immediately you'll know
um but he wasn't he was confused at
first and then he realized oh geez i'm
in a whale
what do i do uh what a predicament and
he was in the whale for 30 seconds and
he was spit back out
supposedly now like i said this is
i've seen these headlines everywhere
people are reporting this
and usually just like not even a lobster
diver claims he was swallowed by a
whale just lobster diver swallowed by
whale
and then you think uh okay is there any
evidence that this happened at all
i mean was he injured no he did go to a
hospital but you could see
the the picture of him he's got the
thumbs up he's looking perfectly fine no
serious injuries at all
and um but then then okay well there
were a bunch of boats all around did
anyone see this happen this would seem
to be a pretty noticeable occurrence
if you see a guy get swallowed by a
whale then spit back out
you'd probably notice that you might
even come out and say hey i saw that
that was crazy
well so far i don't think anyone has
attested to this except for
uh one of the crew josiah mayo was
on the boat as well and he supposedly
saw this
but we haven't heard from him we've
heard from the guy
packard we've heard from his sister
who's telling us what the other guy says
so packard's sister cynthia packard
spoke with crewman josiah mayo
who relayed some of the details to her
packard said mayo saw the whale burst to
the surface and that he initially
thought it was a great white shark
again i don't know these are these are
people that have been on the water their
whole lives and they're confusing a
great white shark with a humpback whale
we're talking about one is like 10 times
bigger than the other
there was all this action at the top of
the water packard said mayo told her
then the whale flung her her brother
back into the sea
so um no you know this guy was
swallowed by a whale oh was he really
how do you know that
well his uh his sister talked to another
guy
who said he saw it or no his sister
talked to another guy who said he saw
something
and then the guy told him it was a whale
yeah
come on people i'm gonna give you the
joe biden
rebuttal on this one come on man come on
what all you people doing like clearly
i respect it you know i respect the
story
and if you can make up a story like this
and get away with it i love it
and i understand people want to believe
it i want to believe it too
okay if you want me to believe this
story he should have said he was
abducted by aliens
that i would be on this show right now
defending it
far more plausible why should you watch
the mat wall show i kind of resent
the question frankly i don't have to
explain myself to you
but i will say this if not for the
conservative commentary on raging
liberals
you you should watch because you get you
get all the tips on how to grow which i
which i sprinkle in how to grow a nice
beard
but more than that you get to you get to
just see the bask
in the glory of the beard which i think
is which i'm very happy for you frankly
that you
you have that opportunity to do that
every day and that's also why i got to
tell you about beardsupply.com
i know you all wonder how i get this
beard thick enough to stop communism
from creeping in
and getting into my skin that's a real
that's a real risk the answer is
beardsupply.com men like these products
for their beards women like these
products on their men and for a limited
time when you go to beardsupply.com and
use code
walsh you'll get 50 off your first month
when you subscribe to one of their
already affordable beard oils costing
you less
than eight dollars not only does 50 off
the first month sound great
subscribing comes with its own perks as
well like you get your product
of choice automatically delivered one
two or three months your choice
and uh never worry about running out of
product again because it's always going
to be coming in and you know you can run
out of the product and you got to keep
going to the store
don't do that get beard supply and
remember use code walsh for 50 off your
first month of subscription
go sign up right now and uh and i wish
you the best
in your beard growing endeavors again
that's beardsupply.com
all right let's get a couple youtube
comments and then we'll get to the daily
cancellation this is uh from
the natandi says looks like they hit you
with a context label on climate change
yeah the show yet last friday we spoke
briefly about climate change
and they put up a i've never seen this
before they put up something called a
context
label right under the video with a link
with a wikipedia link to climate change
um nothing orwellian about that sheila
winter says
biden is out of his mind senile doesn't
begin to cover it no i think senile
basically covers it actually
i think that kind of kind of sums it up
um justin pierrot says i suspect matt of
being a low-key
louis ck fan nods in approval not really
lo not really low key
louis ck is i think a genius he's a
genius comedian
um i think i probably disagree with his
world view almost entirely if you ever
if he ever became aware of who i am
he would probably hate my guts but all
that said
a brilliant comedian uh and his
cancellation
i thought was always a little bit
suspect especially now with jeffrey
toobin
they both did sort of the same kind of
thing
the only difference is that louis c.k
apparently got
consent from the women that he
performed for shall we say whereas
jeffrey tuban did not
and yet jeffrey tuban's being
rehabilitated so that is a disparity i
don't quite understand
um holly says i'd like to suggest to you
matt that the sweet baby gang
or sbg for short needs its own secret
handshake an idea for you to ponder
uh we could think about the secret
handshake i i can tell you what it won't
be
it won't be elbow touching like these
world leaders at the g7
summit they're they're all they're all
touching each other's elbows like a
bunch of freaks
it's embarrassing
uh and finally chernobyl coleslaw
with our best username of the day says
matt would you rather fight a
horse-sized
duck or 25 duck-sized horses how is this
even
a debate i mean 25 what are what are a
bunch of
duck-sized horses going to do to me i
could easily kick them away
just step on them be no problem what
exactly
they they're horses right they're not
super human horses
with super intelligence what are they
gonna how are they gonna tag team it
exactly
in in this scenario so
i don't think i'd be worried too much
about fighting either of them
but um i'd be a little bit more worried
about stepping into the ring with the uh
horse-sized duck
that's pretty pretty clear thank you for
the question
you know candace owens has a lot to say
and you should really be listening if
you're not already lucky for you
now you can literally just listen no
matter where you are
uh all you need to do is subscribe to
and download candice which is the audio
podcast on apple spotify or wherever
whatever platform you you choose that's
it's all over the place you can find it
whether you're getting an earful of
donald trump's plans for the future adam
corolla's jokes
you're hearing yours truly say something
witty on our panel i think that's
the the number one thing people tune
into the candidate show for i tell
myself anyway
whatever it is you're always guaranteed
a smart and funny listening experience
so go download and subscribe to candace
the audio podcast on apple spotify or
other podcast apps and remember to leave
that five-star review
if you like what you hear also some
people walk away from drugs and
debauchery and some people walk away
from leftism which i would argue is
worse than drugs
and harder to quit but whenever someone
accomplishes that walk away they offer
an entirely new and interesting
perspective regarding the terrors of
leftism
that's why i'd like to congratulate our
very own georgia howe on accomplishing a
successful walk away
from the left and starting her own
podcast here at the daily wire
whether it's discussing critical race
theory or transgenderism or talking
about america's education system
whatever it is it's all there
uh with georgia house so you can
subscribe and download office hours with
georgia how on apple podcasts or
whatever your platform of choice may be
and get ready for the ultimate listening
experience no matter where you are
now let's get to our daily cancellation
for our daily cancellation we dive back
into our country's racial hysteria in
order to cancel npr
for this editorial just published
yesterday titled tom hanks is a
non-racist
it's time for him to be anti-racist now
tom hanks
as you may have heard recently published
his own editorial about the tulsa race
massacre where he argued that history
the history we're taught focuses too
much on white people and glosses over
our racist past basically making a
similar argument to the one advanced by
joy reid
and robert reich in our opening tom
hanks in fairness though is uh not as
stupid as joy reid but then again tom
hanks's volleyball and castaway
isn't as stupid as joy reid pretty low
bar to get over in any case
the point is that tom hanks is a white
celebrity
who wrote an op-ed to discuss the evil
of racism and the alleged white washing
of history and so on
if you haven't been paying attention you
might think that this this would please
the left-wing race activists they'd be
happy about it they would say oh
thanks tom hanks for supporting us but
because you haven't been paying
attention you don't realize that their
whole game is to not ever be pleased by
anything
and that's what gives rise to this
article in npr from a guy named eric
degens eric
gives hanks a nice pat on the head and a
sticker for his effort but then he
explains
that he's still very disappointed he
writes quote
when i saw hanks that when i saw that
hanks had recently written a guest essay
for the new york times calling for more
widespread teaching about the tulsa race
massacre
when white mobs in oklahoma burned a
prosperous black neighborhood to the
ground in 1921 killing between 100 and
300 people
i was sincerely heartened now i thought
we'll see him examine how his work so
often focused on the achievements of
virtuous white male americans
and may have made it tougher for tales
about atrocities such as tulsa to find
similar space
but he didn't fully go there he then
quotes a few lines from hank's pieces
from hank's piece and then says quote
these are wise words
and it's wonderful that hanks stepped
forward to advocate for teaching about
a race-based massacre indirectly pushing
back against all the hyperventilation
ventilating about uh critical race
theory that's too often more about
silencing such lessons on america's
darkest chapters
but it is not enough
and of course it isn't it never is tom
hanks
could have ran through the streets
weeping
and whipping himself and screaming i'm
sorry i'm sorry
and it still would not have been enough
but in this case tom hanks had the
audacity to not apologize at all
and eric degens is quite upset about
that he continues after many years of
speaking out about race and media in
america
i know the toughest thing for some white
americans especially those who consider
themselves
advocates against racism is to admit how
they were personally and specifically
connected to the elevation of white
culture over other cultures
in other words he is a baby boomer star
who has built a sizeable part of his
career on stories about american white
men doing the right thing
he's not alone superstar director steven
spielberg has a similar pedigree
non-withstanding occasional projects
like the color purple
and amistad and fellow director ron
howard
these stories of white americans
smashing the nazi war machine or riding
rockets into space
are important but they often leave out
how black soldiers returned home from
fighting in world war ii
to find that they weren't allowed to use
the gi bill to secure home loans in
certain neighborhoods
or were cheated out of claiming benefits
at all
yes um well it would have been sort of
strange to include that in saving
private ryan
where would you have included the
information about the gi bill in saving
private ryan what did he expect maybe we
could have had the final scene
of an old matt damon standing at tom
hanks's grave
thinking about whether or not he had
earned this and then quickly it would
cut to a black man being denied use of
the gi bill
then roll credits or better yet
they can do a remake of saving private
ryan where matt damon's character
survives the war
and then ironically becomes a nazi and
at the end he's assassinated by a black
disabled non-binary lesbian ninja
i mean i don't mean to give hollywood
any ideas but this really is the point
that the writer is making he's angry
that tom hanks
portrays white people doing good things
white people are villains eric diggins
believes and that is their rightful role
in any film
to close out the piece degens gives
hanks some homework assignments or
action items to use modern parlance he
says quote
if he really wants to make a difference
hanks and other stars need to talk
specifically about how their work has
contributed to these problems and how
they will change
they need to make specific commitments
to changing the conversation in story
subjects casting and execution
that's the truly hard work of building
change rather than talk about the
historically based fiction entertainment
uh what it must do why not talk about
what tom hanks
long-time scripted and documentary
executive producer will do
as a star who can get a movie made just
by agreeing to appear in it
what will tom hanks movie star actually
do
people often say columns such as the one
by hanks are published to start a
conversation well
here's my suggestion let's make part of
that conversation how baby boomer
filmmakers have made fortunes amplifying
ideas of white american exceptionalism
and heroism
and now their responsibility now now
lies
with uh helping dismantle and broaden
the ideas that they help cement
in the american mind yes we would want
to cement the idea
that white people do good things that's
very dangerous you know
it's dangerous to give people the
impression that white people are capable
of positive actions
the safest and best thing is to place an
entire race of people in the villain
role
and uh keep them there because as we've
seen through history that always works
out well
right all this of course is racist
nonsense
this is a man who simply hates white
people and can't contain it and
fortunately for him he doesn't have to
contain it
we can only imagine the reaction to an
editorial arguing
uh arguing that there shouldn't be
movies that amplify ideas of black
heroism
can you imagine an editorial about i
don't know black panther
where it's a white a white writer saying
you know i
this movie's a little problematic
because uh it kind of gives this idea of
black heroism
and i'm unsure about that i think
can you imagine that you can't imagine
it or rather you can only imagine it
because such an editorial
could never actually be published and
even if it could
there isn't anyone who would be
interested in writing it
but that doesn't satisfy eric degens
nothing
ever can or will it's not enough for tom
hanks to denounce racism
he needs to actively demonize white
people in his films
eric has given hanks his marching orders
his next movie must be a story about a
wealthy white republican oil executive
discriminating against a bisexual native
american climate activist
and then in the end he has to be thrown
down an oil well
and as he's falling asked to shout i'm
white and evil and i'm sorry
just to make sure the point was clear
anything less than that
and hanks will be a part of the problem
and the problem for degen
is that there isn't enough anti-white
sentiment out there
and there never will be because that's
how it's all set up
and that's why npr and eric degen are
most assuredly canceled and we'll leave
it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadasky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nika geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show megan v
stallion teaches me a lesson about true
equality and female empowerment
and joe biden is in europe but he really
has no idea that he's in europe that's
today on the ben shapiro shall give it a
listen